ready as I'll ever be you really think
ice close me all that different females
cool I don't want people to think I'm a
loser
worst case you always have any shoes
[Music]
keeping it clean tidy oh no not again
everyone is on her feet I see Maddy's
eyebrows from last weekend on fleek what
about this go with the football it's
more iconic like it's you know so son
I'm so right yes oh you still don't have
a date for the prom
[Music]
Maddi it's not what it looks like so
it's not my boyfriend and best friend
making out for some optical illusion of
that well if you believe that then yes
oh my God why are you doing this now
I know how much being crowned Queen
means to you which only makes me want it
more now just reflect and listen to my
urine and the water I reflected my whole
life has been a lie Maddie what's wrong
hey that is going if we thought that
popular kids in school had anything to
get this upset about maybe she's not
that popular okay why did all of this
have to happen right before prom that's
it what's it prom what if we ruined it
who would want to help us every kid you
and your ex friends ever made fun of the
sweat stain on your back looks like the
United States of America I'm posting
this there's news for all the a-holes
and destroyed high school crush
we're in well make it a night that they
never for that she's gonna take a selfie
hold on we have to take at least 40 or
50 to make sure we all look good part of
me just wishes I could go to prom
destroy that problem let me take off
those tighty whities are you high but
that doesn't mean I don't mean what I
say
[Music]
you guys ready to make this a problem
they will never forget
hell yes so turned on right now
how do you do this 39 more here you go
[Music]
you